SPEAKER 1: Hi.
In this video, we
are going to walk you
through a demo of
Contact Center AI that
helps states and
local governments
roll out COVID
vaccines effectively.
SPEAKER 2: Hello.
I'm a Virtual Agent for the
State COVID-19 Response Center.
I can help you
determine when you
will be eligible for
the COVID-19 vaccine,
and where you can
get vaccinated.
How can I help you?
SPEAKER 1: Is the vaccine free?
SPEAKER 2: Yes, the
COVID-19 vaccines
will be available at no cost.
What else can I help you with?
SPEAKER 1: Do COVID-19
vaccines contain
animal-based ingredients?
SPEAKER 2: No, the manufacturing
process of the Moderna
and Pfizer BioNTech COVID-19
vaccines are cell-free,
and both vaccines contain
no human or animal products,
preservatives, or adjuvants,
and utilize no ingredients
of human or animal origin.
What else can I help you with?
SPEAKER 1: Am I eligible
for the COVID vaccine?
SPEAKER 2: The state's
prioritization strategy
for vaccine
distribution is designed
to ensure early vaccination of
the most vulnerable citizens.
In order to determine
your eligibility,
I will need to ask you
a series of questions.
Let's get started.
Are you a health care worker
in the ICU, ED, or EMS,
a long-term care facility
worker who regularly interacts
with residents, or a high-risk
long-term care facility
patient?
SPEAKER 1: No.
SPEAKER 2: OK.
Are you a first responder,
a teacher or school staff,
a public health worker, an
essential frontline worker
that regularly interacts with
the public, a long-term care
facility patient,
or an individual
in the general
population at high risk
due to comorbidities
and health conditions?
SPEAKER 1: No.
SPEAKER 2: Got it.
Are you either
over 65 years old,
or under 65 years old with
high-risk comorbidities
and health conditions?
SPEAKER 1: No.
SPEAKER 2: OK.
We're down to the
final question.
Now, tell me, are you an
essential worker of any kind?
SPEAKER 1: No.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you.
I have all the
information I need.
The state has adopted
a multiphase approach
to vaccine distribution.
Based on your responses, you
are eligible for the COVID-19
vaccine in phase 5.
You can find
specific information
about vaccine availability
in the state's COVID-19
vaccination program document
at www.governor.state.gov.
What else can I help you with?
SPEAKER 1: Where can I
get the COVID-19 vaccine?
SPEAKER 2: I'd be glad
to help with that.
In order to find the
closest location where
you can get a vaccination,
please provide me
your five-digit zip code.
SPEAKER 1: My zip code is 10011.
SPEAKER 2: Got it.
That's 10011.
Based on this information, your
closest vaccination location
is Pharmacy A at 475
Sixth Avenue, New York.
What else can I help you with?
SPEAKER 1: Is there
some other location?
SPEAKER 2: The
next location where
you can get a vaccine would
be Pharmacy B at 205 Eighth
Avenue, New York.
What else can I help you with?
SPEAKER 1: Actually, I
would prefer a hospital.
SPEAKER 2: OK.
The nearest hospital where
you can get the vaccine
is Medical Center C at 325
West 15th Street, New York.
What else can I help you with?
SPEAKER 1: I want to
talk to a representative.
SPEAKER 2: Sure.
Please hold while
I transfer you.
SPEAKER 3: Hello.
Welcome to the State
Department of Health.
How can I help you?
SPEAKER 1: Hey, so
I wanted to know,
will the vaccine give me COVID?
SPEAKER 3: No.
None of the vaccines
being studied
are made of materials
that can cause disease.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Can I get any allergic reaction
from the COVID-19 vaccine?
SPEAKER 3: That's
a great question.
People can have
allergic reactions
to any medication or biological
products, such as a vaccine.
Did I answer your question?
SPEAKER 1: I think so.
Thank you so much.
SPEAKER 3: OK, thank you.
Bye, bye.
SPEAKER 1: Bye.
What you just saw there was the
agent getting a recommendation
from the knowledge base for
the commonly-asked questions.
They did not have to
look for the information.
And there's also a
thumbs up or thumbs down,
which can be used by the
agent to provide feedback
to the system that
this response was good.
This helps the Agent Assist to
incorporate the agent feedback.
Thanks for watching.
And if you're looking for more
details on Contact Center AI
solution, we have
included the link below.